So today we start a series on the
entirety of human history. We'll be
going very fast and again what's
important is for you to understand the
concepts
and so if there are ideas you don't
understand it's very important that you
raise your hand challenge me and ask for
clarification.
So we start off with the dawn of
humanity
and
um this is Charles Darwin
and arguably he is the most influential
thinker of the past 20 years and the
reason why is he wrote a book called the
origin of species and he presents to us
the theory of evolution
and you all know the theory of evolution
because they teach this to you in school
and is embedded in our everyday lives.
And there are three main ideas to the
theory of evolution. The first is that
it was all accidental. So you have these
genetic mutations and the mutation that
is best fitted to survive in environment
would win out. Okay? So it's all a
random accidental process. That's the
first thing. Second thing is that it is
materialistic meaning everything that
you can see is all that exists. And the
third thing is it is emergent meaning
that feel things build on top of each
other. It is a bottomup process. Now the
the fear of evolution
marked a turning point in in human
history because before
um European countries were Christian and
Christians believe that there was a
divine God who created us and as such we
were all equal before the eyes of God.
Therefore you cannot go and enslave
other people. You cannot go and kill
other people as well. There were three
main ideas to Christianity. Okay. Okay.
The first idea is one omniscient and
omnipresent God.
The spirit, the Holy Spirit is what
infuses
uh life. It's what gives meaning and
purpose to life. And the world is a
mystery. We have to hold faith. There
are things that we cannot understand.
God has a plan, but it is a mysterious
plan. And so, we must uh be humble and
serve the purpose of God. Okay? And the
theory of evolution destroys this
concept conception of the universe and
introduces a more materialistic one. So
why did this happen? Well, it happened
for three reasons. The main purp the
main reason is that we live in an in the
19th century when Darism came into being
Europeans were engaged in a process of
imperialism. They were going around the
world and conquering other people and
colonizing other people and essentially
committing genocide. So they needed a
theory to explain why this this
happening and Darwin's theory of
surround the fittest was the most
appropriate theory and the idea is that
the world is divided into races and of
and the white race is superior to
everyone else and therefore the white
race um has reason has legitimacy in
colonizing other people. Um and
evolution would give rise to racism and
eugenics. Okay. So before Darwinism, we
didn't really have a concept of race
because everyone was equal in the eyes
of God. And now with the rise of
Darwinism, the world is divided
according to race as well. Because of
evolution theory, people started to
believe in eugenics, which is the idea
that stupid people, people who are not
white, they should be sterilized because
if we if we let them live, they would
just all they would do is dilute the
genetic pool. Okay? And even today,
guys, there are still many people who
believe in racism and eugenics. The
thing about evolution that's very
important is that it's a theology. Okay?
What does that mean? means that it's a
theory of human progress about God. So
even though evolution thinks that
genetic mutation is an accident, the
theology is that well the strong survive
and that's what's right. Okay, so might
makes right. So in many ways evolution
is a rejection of Christianity. So you
would think that Christians would oppose
Darwinism and evolutionary theory. But
what was surprising is that when the
book came out in 1859 only in 20 years
the theory of evolution would come to
dominate the entire western world. It be
it became the dominant idea in schools
in universities in the sciences. And
even today evolution is a dominant
paradigm meaning that you cannot
question evolution. If you question
evolution it means you're crazy. Okay
but I'm crazy. So we're going to
question evolution today. All right. So
you've said this in school all but
evolution means we came from monkeys,
apes and then there were different
species of humans and eventually the
best our species the homo sapiens won
out. Okay.
So what evolution says is that we are
just a monkey guys. Okay. We're just a
monkey. And what do monkeys do? Monkeys
like to have sex. Monkeys like to eat.
Monkeys like to fart. That's all we are.
We're just monkeys. All right.
And this is the evolutionary tree of
primates.
The but there are certain problems with
this theory. Okay. The first problem is
if you look at evolutionary theory, what
you should have is tremendous diversity
as the species develops. But so why is
it that we only have one human species?
Okay, why aren't there many different
ones? Well, the argument is that um
there are there were many different
species before but we want out. Okay.
Okay, that's fine. But another problem
is
why are we going all around the world?
Okay. So all species of human beings
like to migrate
but primates don't do that.
Why is that? Humans like to migrate. And
so the explanation often is well because
of climate change, because of war,
because humans are chasing game. Okay,
bisonens and and and food. But then how
do you explain these people? Okay, the
these are people who went to populate
the Pacific islands, Micronia. That's
kind of weird. First of all, it's really
dangerous to go out the Pacific for
months and months, right? Also, like,
how do they know that there'll be
islands waiting for them in the Pacific?
So, that's something that's very odd
about human beings. In fact, there are
lots of things that are really odd about
us that other animals don't do. For
example,
we're very religious. Okay.
Okay. So, the Neanthods are supposed to
be before Homo sapiens. But as you can
see, what we've discovered are these
religious ritual sites, the Neanthals
where the anthos engage in religious
ritual practice. That's kind of weird.
What does religion have to do with
survival? In fact, you can argue that
religion is a waste of time. Why aren't
they hunting? Why are they using so so
much resources and time in building
these uh ritual sites? Okay,
Homo sapiens
did cave paintings and these cave
paintings I will show you later on.
They're very extremely elaborate. As you
can see, it's very time consuming
uh to actually do these paintings.
Also, these paintings are in caves, deep
inside caves that's very cold and where
there isn't much ear. So, it's kind of
dangerous actually to be in these
places. But we know that homo sapiens
spend a lot of time in these deep wet
caves drawing these paintings. That's
not very utarian. Why would we why would
we do that?
So, that's a mystery. Okay. Also, um,
when we drew on caves, we figured out
how to make it artistic. So, we figure
out that red ochre would give us red
yellow pigment on the caves. We also use
charcoal to use black. Okay? So, we were
very creative. We were very we
resourceful.
All right? So we know a lot about the
ice age because as you can imagine
during the ice age things freeze over so
they can be easily preserved and
actually for most of human history uh we
were in the ice age period.
Okay and as you can see during the ice
age the entire world was basically
frozen over. So how did we survive? We
survived by using the resources around
us. Okay, so this is a mammoth and so
they killed a mammoth and they turned
the mammoth into a house.
Okay, now the question is how did they
know how to do that?
How did they figure it out? And we've
been trying for a long time to figure
this out. But my answer to you, and this
is a theme that I will
uh keep on emphasizing for the rest of
the rest of semester, is they just knew
it. Okay. So, let's do a thought
experiment. Let's just say that we
there's 10 of us and I give you this
wall, right? And I say to you, you
cannot talk. You cannot communicate with
each other. All I want you to do is draw
a picture. Now, you would think that the
picture would be disgustingly ugly. It
would be incoherent.
But if you actually to do this
experiment, something weird and
wonderful would happen. Okay, there's 10
of you. You're not communicating. You
don't have a plan. There's no draft. But
one of you would draw something. Okay?
And then the rest of you would see that
something and then you would draw
something else. Okay? So for example,
maybe you draw a sun, then you draw a
tree, then that other person draws a
mountain. Okay? It's almost like
telepathy.
And that's how we are. If you put humans
in a group, they would know instantly
how to work together. They would know
how to share ideas together. And so
that's the idea I want to present to
you. All this stuff is all all this is
because of intuition. Okay? No one said,
"Hey, there's a mammoth. Let's go kill
it for food and for housing and for
clothing." But if you walk together and
you saw a man, you all of you together
had the same thought. Oh, that could be
a source of food and clothing and
shelter for us. and you all knew how to
work together. That's the beauty of the
human imagination and the human empathy.
And that's something that back then they
practice a lot, but we've lost because
of civilization.
Okay? Does that make sense to you guys?
All right.
Um, and as you can see, back then,
humans were just very good at working
together.
No, there you didn't have need to have a
boss to say, "Okay, you should go and
hunt bisons. You should go and you
should make clothes. You should go and
you should feed kids." Everyone knew
exactly what to do and you didn't have
to communicate. But also, what's really
interesting about this time period is
the diversity of human organization. So,
what I meant by that, what what I mean
by that is that in different times of
the year, in different locations, humans
would form different organizations. So
most of the time maybe there'll be
groups of like five to 10 would go and
get food. Okay. But then you have some
times of the year when you have these
religious festivals where hundreds
possibly thousands got together and you
celebrated your god together. It was all
intuitive. You didn't have communication
but they all knew at what time what
organization would best fit them. If you
didn't like the situation, guess what?
You'd go somewhere else and start your
own organization. Okay? So mo early
human history it's a very diverse very
dynamic very creative period in our
lives even though we've forgotten about
it. Okay. And the third example of our
creativity are these cave paintings that
that were discovered uh recently but
which date back 30,000 40,000 years.
Okay. You can see how beautiful these
paintings are. Whoever painted these
paintings put a lot of care and devotion
into them. Okay, it was it's not just
kids playing. It's adults who spent a
long time purposefully ensuring that
every detail is exact. Okay, then the
question then is how do they do this?
Because there's no paper, there's no
planning. And again, I present to you
the idea the imagination. They dreamt
this. They had a dream. They saw the
picture in their heads and they went and
drew this in a cave because they wanted
to express themselves. They wanted to
leave a legacy. They wanted to leave a
memory. There's a calling in you to be
creative and to be imaginative.
Okay.
All right. So, and you can see there's a
lot of diversity. Um, this is a story,
right? Because you have these uh horses,
but then you have these predators,
lions. Okay. So this picture is telling
a mythology. It's a telling a story of
how nature works. Okay? So people are
observing nature and what they see is a
cycle of life and death, of destruction
and renewal. We're all
together. We're all unified. We're all
one. It's balance and harmony. And
that's why
if you were to kill these animals, you
also had to commemorate them. Okay, does
that make sense? Okay, because this this
is a word of balance and harmony. If you
kill these animals and you eat their
food, you must thank them for the
sacrifice by commemorating them. The
same thing as later on uh when humans
fight in battles, we build monuments to
celebrate those those who were fallen,
right? Because we want to create balance
and harmony in the world. We want to
commemorate those who made our lives
possible. Okay. So in this world, what
matters are these animals because these
animals are what gives humans food
um and clothing.
Okay.
Okay. You can see how beautiful these
pictures are. Like you do you see how
lifelike the animals are? Okay. So
clearly we humans had all this creative
potential
back then.
All right.
Okay. This is in Spain
when Alamera.
This is a bison. And you can see the red
ochre how beautiful it is. Okay.
Okay. And you can see how it's not meant
to be realistic. It's meant to be
surreal. It's meant almost to be a
mythology. There's there's there's a
story being told in these pictures. We
don't know what the story is, but you
can imagine that there's story of life
and death, destruction and renewal.
Okay? And you can see
the struggle of humanity
to get food from nature, but also a
willingness to celebrate those who have
fallen.
Um, and there's religious significance
to everything these campaignings. How do
we know? Because this is clearly a
shaman, right? What we call a leper man.
This dates back to 40,000 years in
Germany. So we believe that in the early
societies the shamans were the leaders
because they had the most wisdom because
they had a connection to the vine. Also
what's really important is that music
okay this instrument was really
important to these to these
civilizations. Now there's a lot of
mystery as to how we first spoke and as
I said actually we don't really need to
speak because we can all understand each
other. So why do we speak? Because we
want to sing. Okay, does that make
sense? Singing, creating music was a way
to express ourselves in the same way as
painting was.
And music once you add words, it becomes
storytelling. And that's why we created
language. Okay? Not for economic
reasons, not in order to create a
hierarchy, but for creative reasons to
celebrate our humanity together.
And these pictures as you can see there
are um religious elements. Okay. So you
can see how there are two almost bird
figures and um back then the bird
signify mother earth. Okay. So the bird
figure is very important. You can see
almost like the bird figures are leading
the animals
uh hurting the animals across. So then
ask yourself why are they why are these
paintings appearing in caves? Well
for these people they all believe that
um nature was connected right and the
spirit world and material world were
connected together. So then the question
then is how does the spirit world
connect with the material world? Well
through caves right through portals
rivers caves mountaintops. And that's
why these places were considered
appropriate sites for religious ritual.
Okay? And that's why you painted these
pictures in caves because these caves
you it's almost like you're summoning
the spirit of these animals to return,
right? You've killed these animals. How
do you get them to return? By calling
for them in these caves, right? Right.
So, as you can see, it's a complex but a
complete mythology of how the world
works. And for them, this was very real.
Okay?
And you can see how these shamans would
actually turn themselves into these bees
in order to better communicate with
them. Okay? Because these bees, these
animals, these bisonens were the basis
for all life on Earth. If you didn't
have them, then you would die off. So
you dressed up like them in order to
better communicate with them in the
spirit world to draw them back.
Okay.
Okay. So this is another religious
depiction.
All right. So these cave paintings,
there's always three questions
associated with these cave paintings.
The first is how are they painting
caves? What are they painting? And where
and why are they doing this? Okay. And
I've I I've explained to you there is
religious significance to what they're
doing. They're trying to complete the
cycle of life and death. If you kill an
animal, you have to you have to thank
the animal. Okay? You do that by making
a religious sacrifice. Okay? By sorry,
by making a religious ritual. Um what
are they painting? They're painting the
story of life itself, right? They're
trying to paint a picture of how life
works. a cycle of death and life,
destruction and renewal and everything's
connected together. The stars, the caves
are portals into the spirit world and
that's why you celebrate them. Okay? And
um how are they painted in the caves? Um
they're painted together and they're
using um red ochre and charcoal. What's
most important is that
because these caves actually lack oxygen
when they're painting when they're
painting these uh paintings, it's almost
like they're in a trans state. Okay,
does that make sense? Because you don't
have enough to um um breathe. So, it's
almost like you're you're you're on the
precipice, the edge of life and death.
And it's almost as though you are
actually communicating communicating
with the spirit world as you're doing
this. So it's all divine inspiration,
all divine intuition. Okay. So what they
believe is that when they paint, they're
channeling the power of the spirit
world. It's not about us using our
experience to paint. It's we are
channeling actually the divine when we
do so. Okay. And the same thing when we
sing or when we tell stories. We're not
doing this out of our own will. We are
we are only a portal or a mechanism or
channel for the divine to communicate
with everyone else. Okay. So, does this
make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
All right. The other thing that's really
interesting about these cave paintings
is um we find symbols inside these cave
paintings. So this is Genevie von Piter
who is a Canadian archaeologist and she
spent decades going to different uh
caves in Europe and she cataloged all
the different symbols.
Okay, so these are not pictures, they're
symbols and as you can see
there's a lot of them. Okay, so why
would they have these symbols?
And also what's interesting is if you
think about it this is a writing system.
In other words, they had the capacity to
write, but they chose not to write. Why?
Because if you think about it, in this
world, writing is a corruption, right?
When you speak, you're channeling the
vine. So when you are writing something
down, you're actually counterfeiting the
divine. Okay? Also
remember that for them, what's stop
talking is really like singing, right?
And you cannot capture music in the
written form. So it's almost like a
corruption of the song. Okay. And and
also for them, this is really important.
All everything is meant to be a communal
experience. When you sing, when you
talk, when you paint, we do it together.
Okay? But you when you write, it's a
solitary experience. And that's why even
though we humans from a very um like
right from the beginning we had the
capion to write we chose not to write.
Okay, this is really important for us to
understand. Writing was a conscious
decision. It was not something it was
not a technology that was invented later
on. We just chose not to do it because
we thought it was a corruption of the
natural world. Okay. All right. Does
that make sense? Okay. So this is a um
these are all the geometric signs of of
ice age Europe. It's very similar to
alchemy. Okay, alchemy is trying to
figure out the secrets of the universe.
So the question then is where do they
get these signs? And the answer of
course is it came to them in a dream or
they were inspired with these signs.
Okay, this is a world of inspiration, of
intuition, of imagination. It's not
something that's deliberate. They don't
plan this out and discuss it. It just
comes to them and when they draw it out,
it makes sense to people. Oh, I know
what this means. Okay.
All right. So, uh let's summarize. Okay.
Why are the symbols in art? Well,
because there are certain abstraction,
certain concepts you cannot draw out,
right? So, for example, energy is a very
important concept. Life force, cycle,
repetition. Well then you have to use
symbols in order to express uh these
ideas if you want to tell the story.
Okay. Second is you are trying to
visualize the language of the spirit
world. Okay. So the spirit world is
talking to you but they come to you in
images. So you use the symbols in order
to express what what what they're
talking about. Um, and when you draw the
symbols on a stone, you're making the
stone
divine and sacred, right? You're storing
a memory inside the stone. Maybe
something wonderful happened here. Maybe
you gave birth to a child here, right?
Then you commemorate the stone with a
symbol.
Okay, does that make sense?
Okay.
So, why you're doing this is well, first
of all, you're trying to bring beauty to
the world. That's that's why we're we
humans were created, right? To make this
world a more beautiful place, a more
imaginative place to celebrate the
divine. Um we're showing God or the
spirit world or the underlying soul of
reality. Okay? We're trying to figure
out how the spirit world works inside
our reality. The third reason is we're
trying to tell a story about who we are.
Okay? We're trying to combine our
imagination together to create society,
to create belonging, to create
community. Okay? Okay. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> sorry.
>> So, you said about human trying to
connect with the divine spirits, right?
So, do they come?
>> Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Let me clarify.
Okay.
>> This is really important. We're not
trying to connect with the divine
spirit. Why? Because divine spirit is
all around us.
>> We we coexist with the divine.
>> Okay? Everything everything around us is
divine. But what what we're trying to do
is we're trying to be in harmony with
the divine.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Do you understand?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Because because in this world
there's no separation between the
material and the spiritual. It's all one
world together. The spiritual is all
around us. But there are certain things
that we do in order to reconcile our
existence with the spirit world. For
example, we kill an animal. We need to
commemorate the animal through paintings
and through songs. Okay. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Does that answer your question? Yeah.
>> Okay. Good. Okay.
All right. And we even today we still do
this. Okay. So, so let's see examples.
This is graffiti. Okay. Street art. But
you can see what's happening where uh
this is Spain and you can see how
beautiful this is. Okay. It's the same
concept as the K paintings where we're
trying to give meaning to our community.
We're trying to tell story of who we
are, where we came from, and where we're
going. Okay. And it's and it's designed
to um build a common imagination. Okay,
no different from the cape paintings. We
still do this today.
And this is another example. And you can
see different communities might have
different focus. But you can see how the
painting what it does is it unifies the
imagination of the people. Okay. So for
this community what matters is the
family. Okay. So the matriarch, the
mother is the cornerstone of this
community and that's what you do with
this painting.
Okay? You can see how beautiful
these buildings have become because of
the paintings. So that's what art does.
Art gives purpose, meaning
to our world.
All right.
Okay. So, some really important concepts
I need you guys to understand. Okay. And
we'll go over this as a semester
progresses. And these concepts are going
to be counterintuitive for us. Okay? But
the first concept I want you to
understand is preiterate people. Okay?
People who could not read and write.
They were more intuitive. They were more
imaginative. And they were more
empathic.
Okay? Meaning I can know your emotions
right away. I don't have to ask you
anything. I don't I don't have to ask
you how you're feeling today. I know
exactly how you're feeling right away.
Okay. All right.
So we can see this. This is Inuit art.
Okay. So this is art um by native
people. So even in communities of today
that have hold to this tradition, you
can see how they perceive the world,
right? They perceive the world as
unified. The gods are with us. In fact,
everything we do is a celebration of the
gods. So our house is our temple. Okay?
The temple is not a place you go and and
um celebrate the gods. You celebrate the
gods in your house. If you if you have
enough faith to turn your house into a
temple, okay? So this is inward art.
Okay? And if you go to like many native
communities, communities that maintain
the traditions of the ice age, they're
all like this. Okay? In their
perception. But the problem is they
cannot communicate it using modern
language. So we just think they're
stupid. Okay? They can't write essays.
They can't give speeches. And so
therefore we we think they're stupid.
But they're not stupid.
It's just that they're focusing their
energies on empathy, on imagination, on
intuition.
All right. So let's give examples of
empathy in action. And this is this is
true for the entire world. Okay? So once
there was a horse in America that could
do math. All right? So the horse would
go on stage and then the trainer would
ask the horse a question like what's 2
plus two? And the horse would be like
nay nay
nay
nay. And it would be like oh the horse
can do math. Okay? So the horse cannot
do math. Okay? I'm telling you right
now, the horse cannot do math. So what
the what what the horse is doing, you
think about it, is the horse is reading
the room, right? Because the people who
pay the money to go into the theater,
watch the horse do math, obviously
believe the horse can do math. Okay? So
what happens is when the trainer says to
the horse, "What's 2 plus two?" The
horse is nay nay. And the horse is
watching everyone. Okay? And as the as
the horse comes to the answer, the horse
sees that the peoples are like really
excited. Okay, their eyes are bulging,
their breathing is faster because people
are anticip anticipation, right? The
horse is, "Oh, now I know the answer."
Okay, this is empathy. Animals can do
it. We can do it as well. It's actually
our super superpower. Okay, does that
make sense? Right. Second example is
telepathy. So in America right now
there's a very popular pro podcast
called the telepathy tapes. You might
have seen it. You may you may have heard
of it. Okay. The idea is that kids with
autism are able to read the minds of
their parents. Guys I'm telling you
right now kids the autistic kids cannot
do that. They do something else. Okay.
So let me tell you a story of how they
do this. In China there's also a a
similar case where a mother in the
countryside. Okay. So she's not
educated. She has no money but her son
is autistic. It's an autistic boy,
doesn't really speak. Can I make eye
contact? Okay, lots of issues. Can I go
to school? So, one day the mother
contacts CC CCTV, the national
broadcaster, says, "Hey, my son can read
my mind." And you know, these are TV
people. She like, "Okay, this will make
a good documentary." So, they fly all
the way down to this village, this poor
village, and the mother is, you know,
doesn't speak great Chinese. So, they
have to film this process. Okay. So what
happens is the boy is put into a room by
himself. And then the mother is given a
number, okay? Like maybe five. Then the
mother goes and asks the boy, "Please
read my mind." And the and the boy says,
"You saw the number five." And it's
pretty amazing. And of course, it's not
really believable. So this documentary
team spent days and days figure out what
happened. Okay. finally brought on they
brought in artificial intelligence AI.
What the AI AI figured out is
it's the pitch of the voice that gives
the answer. Okay. So now they're saying
read my mind. Read my mind. Okay. And
the difference in the pitch there's a
different number in that pitch. But the
problem is it's so subtle that only the
boy can hear the difference in pitch. We
humans ordinary humans cannot hear the
difference. And so the documentary crew
confronted her and says, "Listen, we the
AI artificial intelligence system tells
us that what you're doing is you're
cheating. You are uh using pitch to give
signals to your son. Is that true?" And
the mother is like, "Yes, I'm sorry.
Yes, it's all a lie. We're poor. My son
is autistic. I want my boy to go to
school. I want my boy to get
professional help." And that's why we
devised this scheme in order to trick
you. So we we can get some television
coverage and then maybe we can get some
donations. Maybe some people will help
us. Okay? And that's why we did the
scheme. And so that's it. But think
about this. Think how amazing it is that
the two together were able to deise a
scheme, right? Think of how think of how
amazing is that they were a that they
were able to devise a scheme that was so
creative that it tricked people. Only an
artificial intelligence system could
figure the system out. Okay, they so
this mother is not educated but she
loves her son and she wants the best for
her son. So she figure out what her
son's special ability is pitch. she able
to hear different sounds and devis a
scheme to make full use of the sun's
ability.
Okay, so that tells us the power of the
human imagination if we truly love
someone.
Okay, so they created a hidden emotional
language together which again is amazing
and it's it's something that that you
will see when two people actually love
each other. they will create their own
language that that only they can
understand.
Like in the last example is some
cooperative painting, right? So we
discussed this where if I put 10 of you
in a room and I give you a blank wall
and I ask you to draw the pictures
you're going to create are going to
pretty be going to be pretty amazing.
Okay? You're not allowed to speak.
You're not allowed to cooperate. You're
not allowed to plan it ahead. But I
guarantee you when the two 10 of you get
together and you start drawing together,
you will draw a great picture. And the
reason why is not because
you want to draw a great picture. It's
because you all want to help each other.
You don't want to let each other down.
Okay? Because of cooperation, because of
empathy, you want to be at your very
best. You want to be at your creative
best. That's the secret to creativity.
Okay? When you're able to find a purpose
and meaning in other people, your
creative potential will be fully
released. Does that make sense?
Okay.
All right. Um, so back to the horse
horse example. If you ride a horse, one
thing that you will learn over time is
the horse can read your mind. Okay. And
so this is a polo game. And if you watch
a polo game, it's pretty amazing because
you're not you can't speak to the horse,
right? But the horse will know exactly
instantaneously what you want to do. If
you want to turn right, the horse knows.
Turn right. Even before you think the
thought, the horse will know.
Okay? And this is why throughout human
history,
warriors on horseback were the greatest
warriors. They were invincible. Why?
Because what happened was basically the
men had four legs. Okay? Because because
in these um uh pneumatic societies where
people fought on horseback, they were
born on horses and they were riding
horses since they were early or since
they were young. And so they developed
this emotional connection with the
horse. So the horse knows exactly what
you think even before you think it.
Okay? And there are lots of examples
like this. If you have a dog, you know
that dogs have telepathy, right? So you
go away for a week and then and when you
come back, the dog is waiting for you at
the door. Then the dog knows you're
coming back. That's the emotional
connection. That's telepathy. Okay. So
te telepathy exists, but it's an
emotional connection. There's no way
that I can actually read your mind, but
I know how you feel even at long
distances.
Okay, does that make sense?
All right.
Um, another important fact about human
beings that is not really understood is
we are obsessed with being creative and
expressing ourselves. That's who we are.
Okay? We are the imagination
personified,
manifested,
made tangible, made visceral. Okay? We
are imagination itself. Our imagination
is resilient and will always find a way
to shine.
Okay? So you may know of people who lose
uh sense right so if you can't see your
hearing improves or these people are
deaf okay so they can't hear but then
able to see much stronger okay and they
use sign language to communicate and one
thing that I've noticed in China is that
when I go to restaurants
now and then there'll be groups of deaf
people communicating with with each
other They're always happier. In fact,
they're the happiest people you will
ever meet in China. And it's not because
they're doing sign language. It's
because deaf people have a deeper
emotional intelligence. And so when when
they're together, they're communicate
emotionally and that brings tremendous
joy and comfort to them. Okay? Does that
make sense? All right. Let's give
another example. This is a great
composer, one of the greatest composers
in human history, Beethoven. His music
is startling. Okay, his famous, his
music is extremely famous. Problem is,
he was deaf.
That's kind of strange. How is it
possible for you to be deaf at the same
time compose some of the world's
greatest music? The answer is he saw the
music. Okay? The music came to him in
dreams and was able to see the picture.
Okay? Because what is music? Music is
vibrations, right? So,
[Music]
but they're like vibrations. They're
waves, right? So, you can actually see
for yourself a movie of vibrations.
And the more symmetrical these
vibrations are, the more beautiful the
music is. Does that make sense? So
because he saw the music, he was able to
create music that was unique in human
history. Others hear the music, but he
saw the uh music and it turned into a
movie. Okay. Of movement.
All right.
This is John Milton. He wrote Paradise
Lost. Problem is he wrote it while he
was blind. Okay. How did he do that?
Because he heard the songs. Okay. He
turned
Paradise Lost into a musical, into
music. So he actually didn't need to
speak it out. He just heard it out.
Okay. So he had um secretaries who wrote
out whatever he sang out. And that's why
when you read periodiz law, it's
actually like music. It's beautiful. One
of the most it's probably the most
beautiful poetry ever composed in the
English language. So you can see how
resilient the human imagination is. If
you want to express yourself, you'll
find a way. Okay? It's all about will.
Do you really want to express yourself?
Because if you do, you'll always find a
way.
Okay.
All right. So, this is another lesson
that you will learn the semester. We are
socialized into mundanity. Our true
selves are divine. Okay? You're normal.
You're boring. You're not talented
because you believe what others tell
you. Okay? Society does not want talent
people. Society does not want
interesting people. Society just wants
robots and slaves. So schools,
companies, organizations socialize you
into mundanity. Okay? Into nothingness.
But if you look at your true self, it is
divine. And I'll give you examples of
this.
Um, a lot of people have Alzheimer's. So
what literally happens is they're losing
their minds. And this is um a
self-portrait of a artist who documented
himself losing his mind. So when he was
first diagnosed, he drew a picture of
himself. Okay? And then a year later, he
drew another picture of himself and on
and on and on. As you can see, by this
time, he's completely lost his sense of
being. Okay?
So you can use this picture as a
metaphor for Alzheimer's and and you can
see for yourself what it means to lose
your mind. But there's another way to
understand this picture which is what's
really happening is that the artist he's
shedding his artifice. He's shedding his
clothing and revealing his true self.
Okay. What Alzheimer's is is losing your
socialization because you're losing your
ability to speak. You're losing your
ability to verbalize your ideas. You're
losing your ability to communicate with
others. And what what's left behind are
three things. First is your spiritual
desires. So, a lot of people with
Alzheimer's for for whatever reason,
they go to church suddenly, okay?
They're not religious. Maybe that maybe
they they're they grow up in an atheist
household. They don't have any
association with religion, but once they
develop Alzheimer's, they have this
spiritual desire to go to church and
pray. It's really amazing. Okay, that's
number one. Number two is they love to
sing. Okay, they don't talk, but they
sing. The third thing is they draw.
Okay, this is a painting by a
Alzheimer's patient. Okay, not great,
but guess what, guys? He did this when
he was like eight years old and he never
painted before.
Okay, that's pretty amazing. Never
painted before. But the moment he had
Alzheimer's, his true divine self opened
up and he wanted to express himself.
Okay. So, what they say about
Alzheimer's is you hear voices, you see
things that aren't there. It's a
hallucination.
But guess what guys, I told you this.
During the ice age era, we all did this.
We all believe that we were we co
coexisted with ghosts, with spirits,
with fairies. Okay? And this was true
throughout most of human history. So
even though yes, medically speaking,
psychologically speaking, these people
with Alzheimer's, they are hearing
voices, but then the reason why is the
voices were always there. We just forgot
about it because we're socialized to
forget about the different forces, the
different voices that exist along along
us. Okay,
this is a person who used psychedelics.
Okay, he's like she's an artist, but
she's using psychedelics. And the thing
about psychedelics is it's almost
similar to um having Alzheimer's where
you shed away your socialization. You
almost enter a spiritual realm. Okay, as
you can see, this is a picture of a cat.
What she's doing is she's drawing a cat
that's the divine cat. Okay? She's
seeing the energy field of the cat.
She's seeing the memory. She's seeing
the aspirations. She's seeing the
intuition, the imagination of the cat
and embedding it into the artwork.
This is another person on psychedelics.
What's interesting is there's no time
and space in art in this art. So, it
becomes almost incomprehensible to us.
Okay. Why is there a helicopter? What's
a cat? Okay. Well, that's how we truly
are. Okay. We don't have a concept of
space and time. We see things as they
are. And and this picture shows you
that. And we can see how the pictures
are. It's a heightened reality. Okay.
Much more vibrant colors.
Okay. Another psychedelic painting.
Okay. As you can see, no concept of time
and space.
Okay, it's all just one unity of things.
Ventang go, okay, the greatest painter
who's ever lived. His paintings are
utterly unique in human history. This is
Star Night. Um, and this is Sunflower.
Okay, but you can see how he has shed
away his socialization. He doesn't care
what this how this is communicated to
other people. All it cares is about the
picture itself.
Okay? So it glows with life.
All right? So let's summarize the
concepts that we've learned. Okay? So
you've been brainwashed into thinking
certain ideas about who we are. They're
not true. The first myth is we humans
are driven by material desires. Okay? So
why do we want uh so what do we want? We
want a lot of money. Okay? Okay, we want
to pass on our genes. We want to marry a
lot of beautiful women who are young and
so they can give us a lot of lot of
babies because we want to pass on our
genes. Okay, and we want to maintain our
status. All we care about is power.
Okay, fundamentally we we we humans are
fundamentally imagination and we care
about three things. The first is we want
to express our religion through art,
music and rituals. We want to know where
we came from, why we're here, where
we're going. Okay, that's who we really
are. That's that's the first thing.
Second thing is we are diverse and want
to differentiate ourselves. Okay, we
want to stand out. We want to be
different. We want we want to be
creative. The third thing is we are
curious and want to explore. And that's
what explains why we go everywhere.
Okay, this has been true throughout
human history. We may not have documents
saying that we were traveling, but we
were traveling because there's always
some of us who want to go and see a new
world, even though it may not exist.
That's who we are fundamentally.
So don't believe people when they say,
"Okay, you just care about money. You
just care about power. You just care
about sex." That's not who we are. We
what we are are fundamentally
religious spiritual beings that want to
create and to love
and to connect. Okay, that's the first
myth. Second myth is the most natural
unit is a family and men want to protect
their property which includes women.
So you maybe you've been taught that
okay men are in charge and women are
just uh animals to
breed babies. Okay, that's not true for
most of human history. It was women who
had control of their bodies. Women could
choose who to sleep with and how many
men to sleep with. And they often chose
to sleep with everyone. Why? Because
sleeping with other men, first of all,
women enjoy it. Okay? But second of all,
it allows women to create social co
cohesion. So for most of human history,
early civilizations, women were the core
and center of all societies. And the
third thing is
there's actually a strategy in sleeping
with many different men because now
everyone is responsible for raising a
child. Does that make sense? If I if I'm
this father and I know exactly who my
children are, then I'm going to protect
my children and and discard everyone
else. Okay? But if no one knows who the
fathers are, everyone responsible for
caring for for taking care of every
single child and that's the best
strategy that they can have. Okay,
because that ensures that every child
becomes um successful. Okay, does that
make sense? Okay, so the second myth
that we will discuss later on. Third
myth, humans follow the iron rule of
nature, survival of the fittest. Okay,
that's that's taught by Darwin. That's
what evolution is. But that's wrong.
Okay. Throughout most of human history,
humans cared for each other. We were
compassionate, empathy, right? We
believe that every cre creature has
divinity and those who are weakest have
the most divinity.
That's why when we kill an animal, we
still thank the animal because we're all
part of the same life cycle. All right.
Number four, humans have gotten smarter
over the centuries. Civilization is far
superior to primitive cultures. Again,
this is wrong. Okay.
The truth is that with the development
of civilization, the human imagination
has decreased. Our brains can be
supercomputers if we allow them to be.
But if people are more creative, which
means they have they have better
memories than we do. Okay? They're able
to recall more stuff. They're able to
store more information. They're more
sensitive, more sensitive perception,
they have more empathy. Okay? They know
exactly how you're feeling, why you're
feeling it, and how to make you feel
better. and uh greater emotional
resilience. Okay, so they're much more
mature than we are.
Number five, we evolve from apes. The
truth is that we are uniquely
imaginative and we can choose our own
evolution. Don't believe we're apes.
Okay, if you believe you're an ape, then
you're an ape. Okay, if you're an ape,
then you like to go beat people up and
like have sex with with like a lot of
women. Okay, but we're not apes. We're
imaginative first and foremost. And as
such we have control over our lives and
something that you have to like learn
for yourself. All right. So let me give
an example of this to conclude the
class. Um this is Roma 2 and we
discovered him 10,000 years ago um in a
bureau site. Okay, this is an ice age
bureau site. He's a dwarf guys.
Okay, he's a dwarf. You can see how
small he is. He's a dwarf.
And you would think that dwarfs don't
really contribute to the community. So
maybe, you know, he's born. It's clear
he's he's um uh deformed. So just kill
the guy, okay? Because he's not going to
have a great life anyway. Instead, what
we found is first of all, he lived to a
pretty old age and he was buried with
um jewelry.
He was buried elaborately. And you only
do that for people you really prize.
That's kind of strange, right? The
people who we think that are most
worthless dwarfs that actually don't do
anything, they actually thought was
divine and deserved a extremely
elaborate ritualized funeral. Why? Okay,
so this is a book um that done
everything by David Grabber and David
Wangro. Great book. Okay, so what they
say is this. When archaeologists
undertake balance appraisals of
huntergather burials from the p
paleothic, they find high frequencies of
health related disabilities, but also
surprising high levels of care until the
time of death and beyond. Since some of
these funerals were remarkably lavish,
this is an amazing idea to think about.
But if you were deformed, if you were
ill, they didn't throw you out. They
spent a lot of time to take care of you.
Even though from their perspective it
was a waste of time and energy because
you're going to die anyway.
So why would they why would they do
that? Well, there are three
possibilities. Okay.
The first possibility is it's really
about maintaining cosmic balance and
harmony. Effing is a cycle. Meaning
what? Meaning we're all part of God. And
if you suffer then we have to make you
better because we're all part of God
together. Okay. So the concepts are
unity of all as above so below. Set a
good example to others. Okay. So that's
the first possibility. Second
possibility is because this is a
pre-iterate society, people have a
stronger sense of empathy and morality.
So they didn't want to see others
suffer.
Okay. And the third possibility is
they appreciate diversity and difference
in a way we don't anymore. Okay. Our
entire school system is designed as
survive the fittest. If you can't do
math, goodbye, you're worthless. If you
can't get 100 on on a test, goodbye,
you're worthless. Okay? But back then,
they saw difference and diversity as
gifts from God. Right? So, if you're a
dwarf, it meant you had something
special to offer. If you're strong,
yeah, you can go hunt animals and you
can protect the the family. But if
you're a dwarf, it meant that you might
have something else to offer. And if we
just celebrate you as someone who has
something special to offer, then you can
offer it to us. Okay? And often what
they could do is well, they could
probably seen better. They could
probably tell better stories. They had
more wisdom. They were have more
intuition. The connection with the
divine. Okay? That's true even today
where the best storytellers, the best
musicians often those who are
marginalized from society, those who are
strangers, who are those who are
outsiders, those who society persecutes.
They probably have greater imagination,
greater intuition, greater empathy. And
today we don't celebrate these things.
But back then they did celebrate those
things. So if you are different, if
you're deformed, if you were ill, they
saw you as blessed rather than cursed.
And that's what we've forgotten today.
Okay. All right. So that's it. This is
just introduction into the entirety of
human history. Okay. We're going to go
pretty fast. Any questions?
Yeah.
>> So would you say that because you made
the examples using um let's you said
Alzheimer's um autistic people. So would
you say that people with um cognitive
disability in like modern age are like
closer to the divine where like we're
returning to the divine by uh abandoning
our cognitive so-called like um you know
the like um logic and everything that
the civilization is. Would you say that
makes us closer would bring us
closer to the divine?
>> Yeah, good question. Okay. Yeah. So, um,
first of all, we're all connected to the
vine. But we just choose to forget we're
connected to the vine. Okay? Why?
Because society, mass society, needs you
to be obedient, needs you to be a
machine, needs you to work, to be
obedient. Okay? So, so the entire point
of school is to separate you from the
divine. Why? Because at an early age,
you're removed from your parents.
Okay? And in school you're taught all
sorts of like really strange knowledge
like 1 plus 1 equals 2. Like what? Who
cares? 1 plus 1 equals two. Okay. But
you're taught this is what matters. Um
and before we would just let kids run
around nature and learn resilience,
learn courage, learn creativity. Okay.
So the entire point of society is to
brainwash you or remove you from the
divine. But there's certain members of
society who can't be um removed from the
vine because we don't want them, right?
So kids who are autistic, uh kids with
disabilities, kids who are just
different. Okay. Once you discard it,
they actually return to the vine. Does
that make sense?
>> Yeah. So is like for example a lot of
people develop cognitive disabilities
after a lot of um like you said being
put into schools um being uh kind of um
limited by the civilization. Would you
say that in that circumstance by
developing or be given a cognitive
disability we're actually reconnecting
with the divine?
>> Okay. Yeah. Okay. So let's clarify.
Okay. So in China, in United States,
everywhere in the world, we're seeing a
massive surge in mental illnesses,
right? So depression, eating disorders,
um suicidal tendencies,
um
>> anxiety,
>> anxiety, fear. Okay. So, so I mean like
it's just an explosion these past 20
years, especially with the uh advent of
mobile phones, social media, the
internet. Okay. So kids lives suck.
Okay. So why are kids so miserable? And
the answer is that when you're born, you
have an automatic connection with the
vine. Okay. So and as you lose this
connection,
you grow more and more confused which
lead leads to anxiety and doubt. And
over time if this confusion is not
addressed properly, then it will lead to
depression. Okay. So another simple way
of saying another simple way of saying
this is we we crave human connection. We
crave
um knowledge of the divine. We crave
purpose and meaning in our lives. But
the social media system has created this
fake system in which we're in prison.
Our imagination is imprisoned in
pursuing activities that absolutely have
no purpose. Right? So on social media
all you care about is likes. How do I
get my friends to like me? like me, like
me. Okay, so you do a sort of silly
things like I don't know post pictures
of you dancing in Hawaii or whatever
even though it g it gives you no
meaning. Okay, so what's happening is
before we cared about what makes us
happy and now we care about what we
think would make other people happy.
Okay, and that's not who we are. Okay,
once you lose that connection to the
vine, then you you can only get lost. So
if you deny your intuition, if you d if
you deny your emotions, then you'll just
become more and more miserable. Okay.
Does that make sense? Okay.
>> Uh like the strong empathy that you just
mentioned, I thought that I'm curious
where the strong empathy come from
because I usually thought that the
empathy is our empathy is shaped by the
socialization and social norms by the
society.
>> Yeah, actually that's a really good
question. Okay. So empathy just means
our connections with others. Okay. And
this something we are born with. So a
mother is born with a emotional
connection with a child, right? And a
child has has emotional connection with
a mother. And over time as this
connection grows their empathy develops
and this empathy almost becomes
telepathic. So that even if the child is
is in school and the child is bullied,
the mother is doing is washing her
clothes. She's like, you know, I don't
feel right. Maybe I should call the
teacher and ask how my child is doing.
Okay. Okay. So, that's what empathy is.
Empathy just means a natural emotional
connection that we're all born with. But
it's entirely possible
um and we know this from our society to
break that connection by setting the
child off to school, by having a child
online too much, by having a child watch
television too much. Okay? Severing
breaking that emotional connection. And
once the emotional connection is broken,
remember empathy, we crave empathy. We
crave emotions more than we crave food.
So it's as though we're becoming zombies
almost, right? If you don't have
empathy, you don't feel connected with
other people. It's as though you become
a zombie. You don't you don't have any
you don't have any direction. You don't
have any purpose. You don't have any
meaning in life anymore. And that's what
leads to tremendous depression. Okay?
Does that make sense? So we are not
socialized into empathy. We are
socialized out of empathy. We're born
into empathy.
Okay.
All right. Great questions. Okay. Any
more questions?
Okay. Great guys. So, I will see you
next time. All right. We'll continue
this next time. Okay. So, I'm just
introducing these concepts, but we'll
expand them and use more examples and
learn more about human history from this
framework. All right. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.